ce soir j'aimerais commencer par vous
faire participer un petit peu j'ai juste
deux petites questions pour vous la
première est la suivante qui parmi vous
a constaté une augmentation des prix
d'énergie ces dernières années ok vous
êtes plutôt nombreux deuxième question
après je vous laisse tranquille
qui parmi vous pensent que ces prix
l'énergie vont continuer d'augmenter
d'accord effectivement en france 22 %
des ménages sont en situation de
vulnérabilité énergétique
on parle aussi de précarité énergétique
ça veut dire qu'un foyer sur cinq a du
mal à payer ses factures d'énergie
énergie électrique chauffage mobilité et
vu qu'on estime que les prix vont
continuer d'augmenter le pourcentage
risque malheureusement d'augmenter donc
on doit faire face un sacré problème
d'énergie et des coûts de l'énergie en
france et pas qu'en france
l'énergie est complexe malheureusement
ne la voit pas on ne voit pas
d'électricité dans les câbles
la chaleur est invisible sur les
bâtiments quand on appuie sur un
interrupteur on ne voit pas d'où
l'électricité d'où les cris cité vient
où elle a été conçue elle était produite
quelles sont ses impacts l'énergie est
complexe et pas seulement invisible
aller complexe est composé de
géopolitique
elle est composée d'économie il ya des
composants technologiques aussi et
surtout l'énergie est fondamentalement
sociologique en france comme aux états
unis
on a le même niveau de vie donc on a des
réfrigérateurs des téléviseurs des
machines à laver
aux etats unis la consommation
électrique par habitant est le double de
celle de la france donc on voit bien que
l'énergie est une question de
comportement est d'usagé et qu'elles
diffèrent selon les pays
les âges et aussi la valeur qu'on peut
donner à l'énergie quand on la comprend
mieux
moi je suis designer et ces quinze
dernières années j'ai travaillé sur
cette question énergétique avec ma
casquette de designers donc je peux pas
vraiment travailler sur les questions
géopolitiques même si elle m'intéresse
au plus haut point le seul la seule
capacité que j'aime moi c'est de
travailler sur la sociologie d'énergie
sûr essayer de la comprendre mieux déjà
moi de la faire comprendre aux autres
donc de partager des expériences
collaborative sur l'énergie et c'est ce
que je vais vous présenter ce soir
premier projet en 1999 avec une avec une
grande équipe de copains passionnés de
musique
moi même je collectionne des disques
depuis depuis pas mal d'années on décide
de faire des fêtes et ceci déconnectés
du réseau électrique et donc on a
construit cette machine aidé par une
association qui oeuvre pour le
développement des énergies renouvelables
basée à lausanne en suisse
et avec cette association n'a pu mettre
au point en fait ce prototype et on
utilise donc des sonos très très
puissante très efficaces en énergie
là on a sur l'image deux fois 1000 watts
ce qui est très très puissant
on a une petite cabine avec des platines
pour les dj et puis on a des panneaux
solaires dessus on a des systèmes pour
afficher l'énergie et puis effectivement
on a bien sûr des batteries pour avoir
un stock tampon pour l'énergie solaire
parce qu'on fait aussi la fête le soir
et puis on a des vélos on a des vélos
installés à côté où c'est le public qui
ces vélos actionne des dynamos et c'est
dynamo permettent de générer l'énergie
24 heures sur 24 pour faire fonctionner
les dj et la sono alors ces systèmes
on les a déplacés dans beaucoup
d'endroits ici dans la rue à paris pour
la techno parade avec le fondateur de
ninja tune un label fameux anglais et
des gens pédales les gens
beaucoup ils sont même ils font même la
queue pour pédaler ils sont très motivés
pour pédaler malgré ce qu'on pourrait
penser tant qu'il ya de la fête
il ya du public qui là on est à
zurich dans une forêt là on est à paris
à la gaîté lyrique dans le parc juste
devant donc les gens pédales ici on est
au domaine de chamarande juste à côté de
paris dans un magnifique parc on est
aussi des fois présent dans les
montagnes dans les alpages avec des
projets qui invite et qui propose de
partager des expériences énergétique
on va même jusqu'à partager de la
raclette solaire pour inviter les
papilles et pas seulement les oreilles
alors ce projet bien sûr il permet à des
gens d'approcher des panneaux solaires
de partager on est tous nous très
concernés par l'énergie donc on répond à
plein de questions et puis ça permet de
montrer aux gens que l'énergie elle
vient pas de nulle part que par exemple
en tout cas pour faire la fête toute la
nuit il va falloir pédaler et tout comme
dans une barrage une éolienne ou encore
une centrale nucléaire c'est une dynamo
qui fabrique l'électricité et donc là on
se confronte au problème de
l'alimentation électrique et on doit
pédaler pour ça fonctionne on partage ce
projet avec beaucoup de pays on a l'idée
d'ouvrir plusieurs antennes une
prochaine peut être à barcelone si tout
va bien
et puis on a ouvert une antenne à paris
récemment où on va construire une
machine totalement intégrée sur un
triporteur à assistance électrique
ziehm projet c'est en 2001 avec l'école
polytechnique fédérale de lausanne dans
le cadre d'une exposition qui s'appelle
l' énergie et climat ou les laboratoires
bien exposées au grand public les choses
des fois pas très compréhensible qu'ils
font donc on les aide à vulgariser en
fait les travaux de laboratoire et là on
voit c'est assez fou ce sont des
cellules solaires des cellules solaires
gré de celles qui fonctionnent avec du
jus de fruits sont des cellules qui
fonctionne avec du jus de fruits des
fruits rouges pas n'importe quel fruit
et on était capable aussi de les
fabriquer en live pour montrer
l'application et faire de la
vulgarisation scientifique
on a développé autour de cette
exposition qu'on a rendu itinérante
toujours avec la der des systèmes
interactifs où on met la main sur un
panneau photovoltaïque et la musique
s'arrête on a aussi des systèmes qui
sont interactifs systématiquement pour
expérimenter touché l'énergie approcher
et mieux la maîtriser mieux la
comprendre
en bas à droite on voit une génératrice
à manivelle
donc on peut la tournée est actionné de
la ventilation actionner de l'éclairage
c'est un petit peu plus dur est actionné
une résistance électrique et là on
comprend que faire de l'électricité
faire de la chaleur avec l'électricité
c'est très très compliqué ça demande une
grande énergie initial
et puis l'hiver on travaille dans les
bâtiments scolaires
on travaille sur les bâtiments avec les
élèves ont fait des équipes avec les
élèves et les profs on utilise des
systèmes pour faire de l'acquisition de
données on
mais des sondes de température qui
enregistrent des températures
chaque 5 secondes et on peut obtenir
comme ça des courbes de température qui
permet de voir la nuit si les bâtiments
sont chauffés ou pas parce que c'est
vrai que dans une école la nuit on n'a
pas tellement besoin de chauffer des
bâtiments scolaires
donc ça permet aussi de faire remonter
de l'information dans la commune et de
dire voilà si on installait un
programmateur sur la chaudière peut-être
qu'on pourrait la rallumer à 5 heures du
matin pour qu'à 8 heures pour les
premiers enfants et prof arrive on
puisse chauffer le bâtiment
et puis on fait appel à un très bel
outil on utilise des caméras thermiques
donc ça permet à des élèves de se
balader dans les bâtiments et d'explorer
et de voir l'invisible de voir la
chaleur dans les bâtiments et d'enfin
comprendre ce que c'est la chaleur dans
un matériau est de voir la dissipation
de la chaleur dans un bâtiment qui est
si abstraite et donc ça permet de faire
très concrètement des économies
d'énergie on utilise aussi des watts m
pour mesurer les appareils électriques
qui souvent même quand ils restent
branchés et qui sont éteints consomment
de l'électricité et donc on fait des
économies d'énergie et ses économies
d'énergie passe de murs de l'école on a
des des parents qui viennent nous voir à
la fin de l'année ou qui vont voir les
professeurs et qui est qui qui nous
disent non mais vous avez fait quoi en
fait avec les enfants là parce que en
fait il était né lumière derrière nous
si on laisse le réfrigérateur ouvert il
leur ferme voilà ils font la police de
l'énergie à la maison eh bien on leur
explique tout simplement qu'on les a
fait participer avec des appareils
wattmètre caméras thermiques sont de
température à des vrais ateliers
d'économie d'énergie et surtout qu'en
début d'année on leur a posé une
question
on leur a dit qu'ils payent
l'électricité et le chauffage dans votre
classe et dans votre école est souvent
les élèves disent c'est le professeur
c'est l'enseignant
alors on leur dit non c'est pas ça c'est
pas c'est pas c'est pas le prof qui paye
malheureusement il aimerait bien que
soit le prof qui paye un peu ils disent
ce que c'est le directeur de l'école
alors non plus c'est pas le directeur de
l'école on leur explique que ce sont vos
parents ce sont les parents qui payent
avec les impôts et indirectement c'est
eux qui payent le chauffage électricité
dans l'école je peux vous dire qu'à
partir de ce moment là en fait les
enfants rentrent dans des dynamiques de
collaboration qui sont très très
intéressante
troisième projet avec mené avec le
centre de recherche de la cité du design
à saint-etienne on a enquêté sur le
phénomène de précarité énergétique
on a travaillé en fait avec des gens
dans leur logement
l'idée de ce projet c'était de ne pas
partir d'à priori de ne pas se dire
voilà les gens sont comme ça avec
l'énergie qui font comme ça et puis ils
ont rien compris et puis de toute façon
voilà nous on sait à leur place on est
allé enquêter pendant plus d'une année
dans de nombreux logements avec des
sociologues des designers on a pris des
photos on a regardé les factures on a
interviewé les gens et puis on a ramassé
tous matériaux et puis on a on l'a bien
secoué on a bien réfléchi
on a bien regardé et puis on a identifié
déjà des bonnes pratiques
donc on a fait un cahier des bonnes
pratiques ensuite on a identifié des
très bonnes installations techniques
déjà existantes donc on a fait un cahier
de recommandations des installations
techniques faut savoir qu'ils avaient
des bailleurs sociaux qui était
partenaire de ce projet et puis on a
fait un laboratoire créatif et on se dit
voilà comment est ce qu'on va pouvoir
endiguer la précarité énergétique en
tout cas apporter des solutions
eh bien on a travaillé sur des aspects
tout à fait simple je dirais presque los
teques basse technologie simple à mettre
en oeuvre bon marché et parmi les 30 40
projets qui existent et qui sont
consultables en ligne
on a ce cette chaussette isolante pour
chauffe eau pourquoi parce que les
chauffe-eau électriques sont
systématiquement sous isolé donc vous
avez en fait une réserve d'eau chaude
dans la maison qui chauffe toute l'année
24 heures sur 24 à 70 degrés pour rien
et donc on a décidé de proposer des
solutions très simples à mettre en
oeuvre et pas réinventer le fil à couper
le beurre énergétique on a travaillé
aussi sur des isolations d'urgence sur
des patchs l'isolation pourquoi parce
qu'il ya des gens on a constaté qu'il ya
plein de gens qui condamne une pièce
l'hiver pourquoi parce qu'il fait trop
froid et donc on se concentre on essaye
de il ya des familles à géométrie
variable
donc il ya des pièces qui sont pas trop
utiliser et donc des fois il ya des
fenêtres qui sont très mal isolé
on a décidé voilà on a inventé des sorts
de patch l'isolation comme ça qui sont
gonflables et qu'on peut installer de
manière saisonnière on peut aussi les
enlever quand il verrait passer et puis
on a travaillé sur la chaleur près du
corps notamment pour les personnes âgées
parce qu'il y avait des personnes âgées
en fait qu'on a interviewé et
effectivement on a créé des soeurs de
bouillottes comme ça murale qui se met 5
6 intègre sur les radiateurs et qu'on
peut rapprocher sur le mobilier mètres
près de soi pour se chauffer près du
corps et puis tout ça fonctionne
uniquement s'il ya un dialogue entre les
bailleurs sociaux et les locataires et
c'est très important c'est l'adn du
projet ce projet s'appelle égale énergie
garantie au locataire et l'adn du projet
c'est vraiment de dire rétablissons un
dialogue entre les bailleurs et les
locataires pour ensuite développer en
fait tout un tas de réponse technique
tout ceci m'amène au dernier projet avec
une première image que vous voyez ici
c'est une imprimante solaire une presse
qui en 1880 pouvez imprimer jusqu'à 500
journaux par heure elle existait à l'été
prototype et par auguste mouchot un
enseignant en mathématiques de tours en
indre et loire qui à partir des années
1860 a commencé à fabriquer des
prototypes de concentrateurs solaires
qui faisait marché des machines à vapeur
et c'est un menteur il a été soutenu au
début et puis d'un seul coup il ya eu du
charbon pas cher qui est arrivé à paris
grâce à une nouvelle ligne de chemin de
fer et à des deals avec les anglais et
ses recherches ont été mises de côté
elles ont été abandonnées et auguste
mouchot est mort dans la misère en 1912
à paris
il a été reconnu par un auteur français
emile zola qui a écrit un livre qui
s'appelle travail que je vous invite à
relire et qui décrit une société
utopique dans laquelle on utiliserait
l'énergie solaire de manière propre et
abondante cette énergie pourrait
résoudre nombre de problèmes et alors
c'est ce qui nous a poussé à monter un
projet qui s'appelle paléo énergétique
dans ce projet on souhaite réinterpréter
on souhaite recueillir les informations
vous même vous connaissez forcément des
gens qui ont entendu parler ou vous même
dans vos lectures dans vos amis dans vos
légendes de pays d' inventions qui ont
malheureusement été non reconnus ou non
identifié qui n'ont pas eu leur heure de
gloire
on a créé ce projet qui s'appelle palais
énergétique et un projet participatif on
a déjà une communauté de chercheurs on
vient de lancer le projet il ya une
semaine et ce projet en fait il propose
de réexaminer l'histoire de l'énergie
par nous et pour nous et je reviens sur
la slide de gens les grès qui est un
auteur un français c'est un docteur
français à l'institut pasteur de tunis
qui dans les années 40 il est connu
puisqu'il inventait le vaccin contre la
fièvre jaune
il découvre que on peut fabriquer de la
biomasse on peut fabriquer du pétrole
avec la biomasse en fait ils identifient
la bactérie biologique qui fabrique le
pétrole jean légré à l'époque est
extrêmement reconnu on parle de
révolution énergétique mondiale malgré
le dépôt d'un brevet derrière il ya
aucune invention il ya aucune recherche
à notre connaissance qui a été poussé
aujourd'hui on a décidé de reprendre ses
recherches avec un laboratoire de bio
hacking à paris qui s'appelle la
paillasse c'est un laboratoire de
biotechnologie collaborative qui
travaille avec un réseau mondial de
chercheurs et on souhaite réexaminer en
fait cette invention avec de nouvelles
briques technologiques
puisqu'aujourd'hui on a des techniques
modernes que jean légré n'avait
certainement pas à l'époque
l'idée c'est de travailler avec
l'intelligence collective de faire appel
à l'intelligence collective pour récrire
l'histoire de l'énergie avec vous on
pense que de nombreuses inventions comme
ces deux là mais il y en a beaucoup sont
tombés dans le domaine public
on souhaite que ensemble on puisse faire
en sorte qu'elles s'y élève
je vous remercie